it really is a disgrace on tuesday
u.s president donald trump released a
video calling the 900 billion dollar
covet relief bill
insufficient suggesting he wouldn't sign
it
on sunday with no reporters or cameras
covering the event
trump signed the bill for an estimated
14 million people who lost their jobs
during the pandemic
trump's timing was off their
unemployment benefits ran out
just before christmas and they'll have
to wait until after
january 1st before the government can
help them
the bill will pay for other things
keeping the federal government
open through september thirtieth the
distribution of covet 19 vaccines
housing assistance and an eviction
moratorium
financial aid for small businesses and
a one-time check of six hundred dollars
to
most americans it means six hundred
dollars which is not a lot of money most
of them say
is far from adequate to meet their needs
but it's something
if he had not signed the bill there
would have been no money
trump had said he wanted the checks
boosted to
two thousand dollars per american adult
something opposition democrats welcomed
and something his fellow republicans
rejected you don't get everything you
want even if you're the president of the
united states
we have a two legislative bodies
and democrats control one republicans
the other
look if they were just the freestanding
government funding bill
i would almost certainly be voting
against that but i think the coveted
relief measures are really really
important
without hearing from trump himself it's
not clear
why he acted now well he did sign the
bill that's the most important thing
and he was under enormous pressure from
republicans who warned him
that it would be very destructive of his
legacy and also of the republican
majority in the senate
if he did not sign the bill donald trump
released a statement saying that not
only did he want congress to cut
some of the spending from the relief
bill but he also wants them to pass
a separate piece of legislation this
week that would give
every american adult two thousand
dollars to help
deal with pandemic related expenses now
the big question is whether or not the
president's fellow republicans
say they're going to go along with this
extra spending
otherwise it's hard to see how the
president will get
what he says he wants rosalind jordan
al jazeera washington well political
analyst eric hamm says it's clear that
trump's main motivation is to keep
republicans and democrats at odds
well this is president donald trump's
last stand at one being relevant but
also to being able to cause more chaos
and discord in washington
this is a president who called the bill
the disgrace even after his own treasury
secretary steve mnuchin was part of the
negotiations that crafted that six
hundred dollar
stimulus check that would go to every
american as well as the additional
unemployment benefits and now here we
are
president donald trump continuing to
threaten to not only
hold uh millions of americans who are
out of work hostage but the entire
nation remember we're not just talking
about a stimulus package but we're also
talking about
funding that would keep the federal
government open and so the president
continued to threaten
only to back down and sign a bill this
is only going to
increase the amount of economic pain
that millions of americans will feel
because now
that's a week that they will have to
forego this much-needed money
and it's also important to note that
many of these issues that the president
was railing against
many of these were issues that was in
the president's own budget that he sent
to congress so we saw the president get
a lot of what he wanted
including money for the border wall
along the u.s mexico southern border
so again these are issues that president
donald trump lobbied for
that he pushed for and he got most of
what he wanted
but now again what we're seeing is a
president who continues to
uh change uh things uh at a moment's
notice and it just sends people into
chaos